en effet le travail sur le langage mais
en tant qu il est le soutènement
symbolique d'un monde de structures qui
sont effectivement celle du capitalisme
financiarisé et soutènement symbolique
ça veut dire que ces structures peuvent
celui de se donner carrière et peuvent
renforcer l'ordre qu'elles soutiennent
grâce à la défiguration langagière qui
est proposé dans la langue qu'on dira
hégémonique en utilisant le concept de
gramsci c'est à dire celles que nous
parlons tous celle qui est devenue la
direction générale de la société et moi
ce qui m'intéresse est effectivement non
personne ne s'en rend les fusils les
fusils pardon j'avais travaillé sur un
compartiment de cette langue qui était
celui qui étayent les logique
actionnariale managériale et qui
s'intitulait dans ma manière de
travailler il faut libérer du cash flow
un seul énoncé est maintenant un seul
énoncé qui est la dette publique c'est
mal cette fois-ci effectivement c'est la
branche de la finance qui est actif sur
les services publics sur les entités
publiques et justement ce qui
m'intéresse en fait c'est de montrer
comment dans tout dans tous les services
publics une même logique de destruction
est à l'oeuvre donc je peux les énumérer
à la poste la sncf edf dans l'éducation
nationale dans la recherche à l'hôpital
public dans l'audiovisuel public dans
l'office national des forêts ou dans les
services judiciaires c'est la même
logique structurelle simplement nous ne
percevons pas avec ça avec netteté et
nous nous distinguons pas sa cohérence
et ceci parce que un discours
automatique a cours depuis trente ans et
que sa répétition même l'a instituée
dans nos esprits comme un système de
certitudes un questionnable donc moi
c'est ça qui m'intéresse c'est de
comprendre comment ces défiguration
opère et d'opposer en quelque sorte par
la littérature une refiguration à toutes
ses opérations de maquillage qui nous
rendent qui en fait nous dépossède de
notre pouvoir politique c'est ce que
j'essayais de dire tout à l'heure
[Musique]